a lasting impact and even
um when i was being interrogated at the
airport
uh no i'm telling you just before my
last day they brought up said listen you
know
just tell us now because obviously the
the you know your file section then
prime minister reveals what you've been
doing you can tell us what you were
really doing it wasn't just your holiday
she said i live with that for asian i
know it was a mistake but it just you
know it lingered um did he apologize and
then and then we talked um not
explicitly then we talked
um
i mean really about the risks for others
you know it's over for us we're home and
and
you can see i'm lighter i'm happier and
fatter again like life is is picking up
but
um there are others left in harm's way
there's been two new french people
picked up uh this week there's a swedish
guy new one and one on death row
and we talk you know about that risk
specifically listener please do what you
can there's a guy
you know when they're really threatening
to execute someone um that's a real red
line and that's a warning signal that if
if they're willing to kill one person
i'll be willing you know everyone's not
safe so please do what you can for murad
and the other brits but also do what you
can for all of those being held and he
said listen i i you know i wasn't aware
of the case but i will do what i can and
you know of course he's just come back
from sweden so so freshman's mind so um
yeah you know warm and and we had one
best part of an hour so
one of the things the nazanin and
richard did ask the prime minister is
whether he would consider giving
evidence to the foreign affairs select
committee which is doing an inquiry into
nazaneen's case and why it took so long
and all the steps taking up to having
her release so they've actually asked if
the prime minister would give evidence
because we think that would be quite
compelling and powerful and he said he
would look into that i was really proud
of nazanin and she was sitting next to
the prime minister and she told him very
clearly and categorically that his words
had a big impact on her and that she
lived in the shadow of his words for the
best part of four and a half years and i
have to say the prime minister looked
quite shocked i think when she said that
but i was really proud she did say that
because and she wanted to make it clear
to him that she's happy now she's
grateful she appreciates the fact that
he she is home now but there was a time
when the words had a big impact and the
other thing i raised is that murad tabas
who's still in iran and was meant to
come home he actually lived in hampstead
and so he was in my constituency before
he went to america and then was detained
in iran so we've got to make sure he
comes back richard you must have felt
very angry all these years the prime
minister's words had had this huge
impact on your wife over in iran no no i
mean like can i stand here now i'm
relieved she's home
i mean i think i think there is a
process to to dig through
what went wrong what might have gone
better um and probably what could be
done to protect people better going
forwards um i mean
open conversation with prime minister
about listen it it's not easy um how you
protect someone with a with a regime
that's willing to do that to other
citizens um
it wasn't i mean you know in fairness
the prime minister you know he thanked
nazanin for she she'd made a hat uh for
wilfred when he was born as the son so
you know thanks for the things that
she'd sent and and you know we talked
about now wilfred's too and um
new daughter and and so
kind of gabriella was yeah and and it
just being you know it's it's nice for
us to be a family back together and did
you talk a bit about how your family is
rebuilding did gabriella say anything to
the prime minister uh so so gabriella
was was given a press of a jigsaw um and
and you know took to making that jigsaw
quite promptly once she got it so um i
think she felt enough grown-up chat and
time to focus on more pressing tasks um
no it was it was
you know and that i mean i was what two
years ago i i stood here having gone in
to see the prime minister um and came
out fairly
um you know for lauren and a sense of
having to battle for longer than i stand
here now the battle over for us
i think there's a there are lessons to
learn there's a wider
yeah there's a wider
problem to ask and we talked about some
i mean there were some mistakes made at
the end that
it was rough at the end um and i think
that does need to be you know when
nazi's ready to talk about it that
there's something to go through
but no i i think
it's not like when this is over that you
feel angry i i think
relief is honestly wonderful the prime
minister didn't explicitly apologize but
do you feel that he accepts that he made
a huge mistake and that it had a big
impact i think it's undeniable um that
that
you know
it's so public um
it you know she said it openly
um it's been said on the telly many many
times and we've all seen it
i said to him i mean you know we often
said better late than never um six years
is a long time
but
you know late is a lot better than ever
it really is and i'm glad they settled
it i'm glad she's home and and
you know in the end they paid the money
and you hope that he now helps others
who are still stranded there so that's
right so we raised murad zabas and
daznin also raised the case of a man
who's on death row who's from sweden
because the prime minister's just come
back from sweden and we've just said the
pressure has to be kept up and nasaling
kept making the point that people
who went in quite soon around the time
she went in they're not home yet and
she's home and she feels very guilty
about that she wants them to be back as
well and she can't sit here enjoy her
life knowing their people going through
the same conditions that she went
through and she talked a bit about what
she went through when she was actually
in jail and it was quite difficult to
hear actually to sit there and listen to
it was i mean it's not like i don't know
the details but to hear it again
quite in the manner that she was laying
it out is quite difficult to hear so it
was pretty stark no not an easy time for
the prime minister over the last hour
hearing her testimony and some of the
important issues that she raised
i think he found it interesting actually
i think he enjoyed meeting her i think
he found it interesting and i think it
wasn't anything he hadn't heard before
in a sense yeah i don't think it was an
abrasive meeting um you know
we're here in happier circumstances than
previous meetings um
yeah i'm glad we are feel a sense of
closure um perhaps not closure i mean
you know i i did mean it when i asked
him you know please do try and give
evidence he said he would look at it i
think
you know he's been a part of our case in
different roles um it's important that
his perspective is shared honestly with
parliament it's important that
parliament does that job to dig into the
government and work out
you know what were the lessons that it
doesn't happen again um and then let's
let's hope that that goes somewhere
thank you richard thank you thank you
thank you